who's the greatest endurance
runner or endurance athlete of all time
oh that's a good question um
i think i'd probably go maybe two
directions here
uh i think uh heli gabar lassie
is one of the best in my opinion
because just i mean
27 world records like not
all the different distance but like
breaking and re-breaking and that sort
of stuff
um i mean he ran two what was it 203
59 before the shoot technology came in
that is estimated at anywhere between a
two to eight percent performance
advantage talking about a two hour
marathon two
zero three yep two hour three minutes
yep yeah so he did that with the old
shoe technology
which uh essentially dates back to
anything if
if you were a nike athlete it could date
back to as early as
i think early 2016 is when the first
prototype started showing up
uh so if you're before that in your
career you are using you're guaranteed
to be using the old shoe technology
um and i mean just the range of it too
and uh yeah it's it's hard i mean
there's
it's uh is he a marathon runner purely
no he did everything that's why i pick
him i think cause he
he he went everywhere everything from
the 800 and his like
at a national 800. yeah at a national
level i don't he wasn't competing
at like olympics or anything in the 800
but he was he was
mostly like 5k to marathon um
yeah yeah so just incredible i mean i i
could go a totally different direction
too i think like steve prefontaine
stands out
in as an american runner just because if
you look at it outside of just like
performances
and stuff like that i think um
he basic like you can't find
an american male runner who
probably didn't get some motivation or
some catalyst into their running journey
from
a prefontaine story or what would you
say is inspiring about prefontaine
like from the philosophy from the
technique from his story
uh i think there's a few things i mean
there's a lot of things which is why he
is who he is
it's uh one was just his attitude about
it where um
he wasn't like this picture ask runner
i mean he was obviously talented but you
know you have the perfect story of like
he wanted to be good at something
like most american kids tried football
no no hard work was going to get
pre-fontaine
starting in varsity for football starts
running
fell in love with a mile uh his college
coach
told him no you're not gonna be a miler
you're gonna be a 5k guy and he
popularized the 5k in the united states
or three mile in some cases
and uh i mean he the way he would race i
think is what
really made him interesting for po folks
where he would
he was just like all guts runner where
he's like he's like i mean one of his
famous quotes was like
if you if you beat me you're going to
have to bleed to do it because he's
going to be in all guts race and
in a sport where it gets very tactical
at times especially at the like
national or i shouldn't say national but
at the like competition level
the championship level where it's like
kind of more of a sit-and-kick
approach a lot of times where everyone's
kind of waiting for someone to make a
move like priy was going to make a move
really early yeah so this idea of
leading from the front which i guess is
tactically
really a bad idea well from a
from a running a pr standpoint it's a
bad idea
in most cases but so race i guess is not
just about the pr mm-hmm so rachel's
about winning
in a lot of cases and that's what he
thought was gonna put him in the best
advantage to win i think
it's just the run from the front i mean
what what do you because you mentioned
this
um the 100 mile you ran you were in
second place in the
in 90s you were able to get to the
first place how hard is it to run when
you're in first place
you know i think this is really
different some people thrive under it
where it's like for them
i mean like i talked about jim walls
before i think he loves being in the
front
if he's in the front he loves it that's
where he's excited that's where he knows
he's
he's doing what he's doing where he's
pushing his limits and things like that
uh preet was probably the same way and i
think there's other folks who are
much more comfortable kind of saying
let's let things settle down here a
little bit
and uh then i'll make my move when it's
time to make my move
or they think of it as and this is a
very important i think lesson for
for the average ultra runner is just
like knowing what you're capable of
is going to be an important piece to the
puzzle because you can like
you you you can try to say i want to run
faster than i'm capable of
in an early part of a 100 miler but then
you're going to pay for it at the end
so really unless you're trying to go for
the win and that's a tactic that you
think is going to produce a win versus
trying to run your fastest time you got
to run within yourself
within your parameters obviously there's
a big question about
where those parameters are in a lot of
cases which makes ultramarathon even
more interesting because it's like
there's so much unknown about it it's
like well maybe you can go faster and we
just don't know yet
so there's in the face of that
uncertainty there's something admirable
like it was with prefontaine
where you take the risk and run faster
than
you know you you think you might be able
to run
in terms of pace that you can hold so
push the pace that's possible yeah
explore the unknown
experience i think it's like a pioneer
spirit right yeah you know the
next frontier kind of a thing but i mean
prefontaine also there's other angles
with him too where he was like in the
amateur era where
to be an olympian you couldn't be pro so
he's turning down i mean the guy was on
food stamps and living in a trailer
because he wanted to run at the olympics
and
there was a lot of like politics
involved with not being able to take
take sponsorship money and things like
that which has changed since then but
uh so he was huge in the movement for
that to kind of like
uh you know have a situation where now
as an athlete you can
finish in most cases finish college sign
a big contract with uh you know a
sponsor and then
also still compete in the olympic games
and go to the events that are actually
ones that are gonna
likely catapult your career in most of
the olympic distance endurance events so
so he just revolutionized a sport and
then to add even more flavor to the
whole thing i mean
he died a very premature death he got in
a car accident and
died before he would have likely
probably meddled at the olympics
so he and there is a tragedy of the fact
that he didn't
yeah well he was fourth place at the
olympics the prior
his first go of it and it was kind of
one of those things where it's like
fourth place at the olympics is the
first man looking out of the first woman
looking out and for a guy that
had as much hype as him i think like a
medal was something he really wanted to
take home with him there and especially
how that race went
i mean yeah i don't know it's it's it's
tragic the whole thing but that's one of
the things that makes olympics amazing
is the tragedy of it like one race
decides
the story of a lifetime which is like
yeah
that's why it's that's why it's amazing
even if a lot of people get hurt because
of it
tragedy makes the the triumph special
right yeah and well it makes i mean it
makes life
like a movie almost where exactly you
know if everything's all
sunshine and rainbows and it's not as
entertaining to watch yeah there's no
adversity to overcome
you